so there's an amazing book called drugs
and travel in 20th century literature
which makes the case that drugs and
travel are so discursive Li entangled so
discursive li intimate that we use the
same metaphors and analogies to describe
the subjective experiences of each I
mean even the term hallucination derives
from the latin term aloo sonata which
means to wander in our minds right so
when we are hallucinating we are
traveling in our heads right why travel
well the hero's journey right this this
map that describes the departure from
the ordinary leaving normal thoughts
behind
24th in the new environment dealing with
conflicts real ones or cognitive ones
slaying the dragon solving the conundrum
in the existential itch then making the
return with a new lesson learned
wandering in our minds and taking the
physical journey both incorporate this
motif of transformation you know an
unfolding that happens in time
we cross over implicit in the in the
term ecstatic drug experience is this
notion of ecstasy be non-static right
pushing through the crossing over the
breaking the threshold the piercing the
veil
the curtain parts and what had never
been seen is devoured by the ayat
we take a trip we call it tripping
you see the analogies you see the
parallels these two discursively
intimate universes reveal to us that the
outer journey and the inner journey
mirror each other in fact they are one
and the same
and I love that right I love that
because I have the travelers itch I have
the wanderlust I I yearn for the holy
other I look at the departure monitors
in the airports listing all those
destination as Alan Dibble dawn cites in
his book the art of travel we look upon
those screens and we think to ourselves
London Amsterdam Prag Berlin Mozambique
South Africa whatever it may be it's
anywhere else but here
right we long to cross over we long to
experience to take the trip to take to
take the journey
you